Tik Tok Tik Tock if you will it is the
is the 24/7 news channel of so many of
our young people and it's like Al jazer
on steroids head of the ADL referring to
Tik Tok as a problem that needed to be
taken care of we have a major major
major generational problem ising the
United States and support for Israel is
not left and right it is young and old
typically the Israelis are good at
people are what's happened here some
wonder why there was such overwhelming
support uh for us to shut down
potentially Tick Tock or other entities
of that nature if you look at the uh
postings on Tik Tok and the number of
mentions of Palestinians relative to
other social media sites it's
overwhelmingly so among Tik Tock uh uh
broadcast so I'd uh i' not that's of of
a real interest and that's where we are
today China or Israel I'll let you be
the
[Music]
judge we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah
subhana brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well so I'm
going to be reacting to a video which is
so so profound Tik Tok was today
absolutely banned in America freedom of
speech freedom of speech of course they
believe in freedom of speech mocking the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon in the
Quran of course the Western World the
liberal World believe in freedom of
speech they're just exposing the self as
we go along the video we're going to
show is going to unravel this journalist
is going to show step by step is the Fe
really China that China has some kind of
you know um data or this security threat
to America or is this something more
Sinister something more deeper than that
the Palestinian Israel war is the
Zionist Israel's behind this once again
let's watch this because it seems like
America is outright owned by Israel it
should be United States of Israel not
America anymore they are even
controlling what you watch because they
realized because the Palestinian cause
is spreading wild alhamdulillah because
people are just in America so let's
watch this video for ourself and let's
take some analysis inall step by step
this is profound is it China no it's not
Tik Tock Tik Tock if you will it is the
is the 247 news channel of so many of
our young people and it's like Al jazer
on steroids in November of 2023 a
recording was leaked of John Jonathan
greenblat the head of the ADL referring
to Tik Tok as a problem that needed to
be taken care of we have a major major
major generational problem the issue in
the United States in support for Israel
is not left and right it is young and
old and so we really have a tick tock
problem a gen Z problem that our
community needs support the same brains
that gave us tag Le the same brains that
gave us all these other amazing
Innovations need to put our energy
toward this like fast so amazing
alhamdulillah so as you can see this guy
ADL the head of ADL this is an outright
Pro Zionist owned by Zionist group yes
and you can clearly see that they are
threatened by that now the question is
why would a foreign country how can a
foreign country
intervene that because Tik Tok
algorithms um and it's a becoming a news
platform where objective news you know
and objective news obviously is is your
pro Hamas if you're objective in that in
your news they've realized that Tik Tok
is a massive threat to the future of
Israel that's the reason why they are
trying every shape or form to ban them
so this is one side of it but here's
what the journalists have to say now one
interesting side note here is that I
came across an ADL report expressing
frustration that they couldn't access
Tik tok's analytics the way they can
with every other big tech company like
should they be able to do that anyway
now we're about a month into this war
and and all these studies started coming
out making claims about the
proliferation of anti-Semitism on Tik
Tok the most notable one from a
statistician and Tech executive named
Anthony Goldblum who tweeted out on
November 30th that a study he commission
concluded 30 minutes a day on Tik Tok
makes someone 177% more anti-semitic
politicians like Nikki Haley would then
go on to regurgitate this claim on
National Television do need to ban Tik
Tok once for all and let me tell you why
for every 30 minutes that someone
watches Tik Tok every day they become
177% more anti-semitic except that
survey didn't say that at all because a
it conflated anti-israel and
anti-semitic sentiments which I believe
to be different and B gold Blum himself
admitted that he made some logical leaps
when he was drawing his conclusion but
now things are really moving at a rapid
pace
the next day on December 1st 2023 the
New York Post reported that a group of
40 mostly Jewish Tech leaders and
business Executives confronted Tik Tok
CEO shoy Chu over their concerns about
anti-Semitism and the allegedly
disproportionate popularity of pro
Palestine videos on the app one of those
Executives Anthony Goldblum the same
Anthony Goldblum who we were just
talking about oh Anthony Goldblum he was
one of those people that went and spoke
to the CEO of Tik Tok and and said
listen
anti-Semitism uh not really my friend
being anti-israel does not make one
anti-semitic yes if somebody is against
a country that is run by Muslims and
those Muslims are doing atrocities
against this Christian minority
population be they Jewish be they who
are whoever they are that doesn't make
them islamophobic you're not going to
come and say you're an islamophobe no
you're not you are speaking about a
country who is doing oppression against
innocent Christian Jews whoever is for
that matter and we're calling out we're
not going to come and say that's
islamophobia no it's not okay that's
being just but no no no so this
individual he was the one who carried
out that uh study yeah okay which was
used in the in the Senate yes by that um
lady and they were just propagating this
as if anti-Semitism equates to uh anti-
Israel sentiments equates to
anti-Semitism this is absolute nonsense
they have destroyed the value of
anti-Semitism so much that should I be
honest with you nobody cares anymore
being called anti-semitic because it
doesn't hold value you are against
objective news let's carry on and from
everything I understand the meeting
didn't go well in the sense that Tik Tok
didn't commit to a kind of wholesale
removal of pro Palestinian or
anti-israel content so from then on the
fight against Tik Tok pivoted from a
kind of PR battle that we were just
looking at to now laying the groundwork
to push legislation through that would
ultimately ban the app in March of 2024
a bill was introduced in Congress HR
7521 called the protecting Americans
from foreign adversary controlled
applications act sponsored by
representative Mike Gallagher foreign
adversary control of what is becoming
the dominant foreign adversary
control you you all the irony oh the
irony so they are scared that China is
having some foreign agent countries
having control h who does that remind me
off APAC oh yeah and we're going to come
to statistics of how many of the senate
members they actually own with finances
let's come toight the irony is crazy
guys let's carry on news platform for
Americans under 30 this is a common
sense measure to protect our national
security I urge my colleagues to support
this critical bipartison legislation the
argument is one we've heard before Tik
Tok owned by the Chinese company bite
dance could pose a threat to US National
Security by harvesting user data and its
algorithm could also be weaponized to
quote brainwash America am an now these
concerns I do think are valid in a sense
but I think it's worth noting that
companies like Facebook and Google
engage in similar data collection
practices and then they would go on to
sell this data to China exactly so if
the threat is that it's China then they
have no problem already because the
thing is Tik Tok I mean Facebook and
Instagram already which is on by meta
they already do that so is the threat
really China
or is there something more Sinister
let's carry on so China is getting the
data anyway but here's where things get
really interesting you start digging
into Gallagher's largest campaign donors
and you uncover a story that goes far
beyond data privacy or Chinese
influence near the top of his donor list
is Apac the Israeli Lobby here's a crazy
statistic for you of the 500 Plus
members of Congress only 33 members did
not receive re a donation from the
Israeli Lobby in the last campaign
cycle that is unbelievable guys just
think that for a second out of
500 members
33 over
90% if I'm yes it's over 90% yes are
owned by Israel your country America's
owned by Israel man what kind of a
voting process is this where you your
your senators are bought how is this how
is this even like you know freedom of
vote who keeps damn about your voting
when you've got these people who are
buying you outright so essentially when
Israel wants something from America they
usually get it now another contributor I
want to draw your attention to paler
Technologies which is a defense
contractor co-founded by billionaire
Peter teal paler just happens to work
very closely with the Israeli military
providing Advanced surveillance and
targeting software used extensively in
their war on Gaza
and one of their Consultants a man named
Jacob hellberg was responsible for
writing the Bill yeah it's incredible a
defense contractor who profits off
Israel's war were also the ones behind
drafting a bill that would in effect
stifle criticism of said War which is a
clear conflict of interests no at around
the same time the Jewish federations of
North America penned a letter to
Congress urging lawmakers to ban Tik
Tock due to anti-semitism ISM not one
mention in their letter about China or
data privacy Tik Tock runs all sorts of
videos that portray uh the Israelis
acting towards the Palestinians in
barbaric ways and when young people see
these videos on Tik Tok portrays what do
you mean portrays it's as if like
they're making it seem as if like for
example the America they spent half a
billion pounds to for to make
anti-islamic videos or whatever it is
for that matter yeah they're outright
pushing this agenda like fake mov mov
what's happening in in in pistan is a
fullblown genocide that is been recorded
in 4k it's the most documented genocide
in history living history brothers and
sisters so they're making it seem as if
Tik Tok is to blame for this the only
thing Tik Tok is blamed for is to give a
platform to those who are recording real
life events simple as that it's
basically saying no we have a problem
with your uh Tik Tok uh platform not
that you're orchestrating this but
you're just documenting this you can't
make stuff up
they obviously become remarkably
sympathetic to the Palestinians and they
think badly to put it mildly of the
Israelis so Lobby would like to shut
down tick tock on March 23rd 2024 HR
7521 pass with largely bipartisan
support looking back I was fully
expecting the bill to pass the house
very very quickly and easily because
there are a lot of bills that pass the
house and don't make it through the
Senate the Senate is meant to slow
things down down but 1 month later on
April 24th the Act passed in the Senate
again with overwhelming by partisan
support and was signed into law by Joe
Biden on the following day like I said I
had never seen a bill go through
Congress with that kind of speed and
velocity with very little opposition or
debate it's wild and maybe even Wilder
by that summer Mike Gallagher the
representative who had sponsored the
bill was now working for volunteer as
their head of Defense he didn't even
finish out his term he just resigned
from Congress and took a job there I
know all of this sounds like a crazy
conspiracy theory in fact the ADL did
call this a conspiracy theory the
Atlantic also called this a conspiracy
theory they even name check me in their
article quote the entire world knows
exactly why the US is trying to ban Tik
Tok you know what maybe they're right
maybe it's a conspiracy theory my friend
whoever you are with my journalist
friend you made this all up but hold on
a second there is a confession from the
horse's own mouth let's watch it for
ourselves James Lee declared on March
16th not bad for your boy here huh and
honestly this would remain a conspiracy
theory I don't know if I would have made
this video if they hadn't come out and
confirmed their true motivations it be
typically the Israelis are good at PR
what's happened here some wonder why
there was such overwhelming support uh
for us to shut down potentially ticktock
or other entities of that nature if you
look at the uh postings on Tik Tok and
the number of mentions of Palestinians
relative to other social media sites
it's overwhelmingly so among Tik Tock uh
uh broadcast so I'd uh i' note that's of
of a real interest and that's where we
are today China or Israel I'll let you
be the judge and that's it guys you
can't make this stuff up alhamdulillah
China has nothing to do with this it's
got nothing to do with China and the
threat of China Etc they're talking
about the foreign power the irony man
it's Israel Israel is the reason why
they got rid of Tik Tok this is going to
go down in history what's happened to
freedom of speech what happen the
freedom of press what happened what
happened the champions of freedom of
speech you hypocrits you don't live by
it like you know it's been said before
yes the West the America they are
strategically consistent not morally
they do not care they are more afraid
that this being documented the public
opinion is being changed that that guy
in the head of APAC said yes which which
was what ad that's what it was yes okay
which is that it's between the old and
the new meaning the older generation
that supported Israel are on their way
out they're dying bye- bye Salam alaykum
janaza bye-bye don't come back yes insh
Hell Fire forever for you but the new
generation are waking up to the reality
and saying hold on a second we have been
sold a big fat lie and the whole world
is waking up to that reality it is not
working whatever the fire do however
they try to maneuver and propagate and
make prop scanda it is not working the
whole world is woken up I have
non-muslims approaching me day by day
and thanking myself Muhammad hijab all
praise belong to Allah but thanking the
movement and saying you know what our
eyes have woken up how cruel and evil
these people are they've massacred men
women and children and isn't it bizarre
isn't it amazing that Allah in the Quran
verse 32 and says and we told the
children of Israel do not kill an
innocent Soul isn't it interesting
that when it comes to this stuff that
they are the most ruthless of not having
any remorse of killing innocent man
women children I'm going to leave this
matter to you guys inah Tik Tok is
banned by the United States of is
America I'll leave at that inshah guys
may Allah bless and guide you inshah
please share this far and wide let the
whole wi know these people don't believe
in freedom of speech they are absolute
Hypocrites and Israel I hope the day
comes your end will come inshallah I'm
talking about the country alhamdulillah
and that it goes back to where
Palestinians Muslims and Christians and
other faiths lived in peace for
thousands of years and when Sal took
over those lands and when took over
those lands they were Christians who
were hostile towards the Jews but they
rather brought the Jews back into this
communities this is Islam Islam is
against any kind of anti-Semitism of any
sort because the prophet's wife was
ethnically Jewish we have nothing
against the Jews yes unless those
corrupt Zionist of course we do anyone
that's evil be Muslim Christian whoever
it is even a Muslim who harms an
innocent person he has to bear the
consequences we are not strategically
consistent we are morally consistent
till next time